the convenience of online shopping may
be great for consumers but it's often
not so good for traditional
brick-and-mortar stores many have closed
in recent years but now there's an
experiment underway near Dallas that
could be a model for the store of the
future Jana Chamberlain is it shamlian
is in Plano Texas to show us Janet what
are they doing in this store of the
future Toni good morning well you might
call it the evolution of the department
store and it is a new concept being
tested here in Texas let me describe it
it's a large open space with a carefully
cultivated selection of products that
usually you can only find online but
here's what shoppers should know as
they're walking around browsing picking
things up cameras in every part of this
store are tracking their every move it
could be the future of retail almost
fourteen thousand square feet of store
that doesn't feel like a store filled
with areas to hang out a very popular
restaurant it's just a nice alternative
place to meet with people and have
business meetings or even just to chill
out and work for a few hours not in the
office sprinkled throughout this
contemporary space more than thirty
trendy brands for the more that you guys
here have this Bailey
from purses and pet products to
sunglasses and shoes neighborhood good
stocks products you can usually find
only on the Internet
walking through its kind of Instagram to
life but I can actually come in and
connect with them it's a department
store slash pop-up where merchants eyes
changes quickly and we're online brands
like Roth these shoes can check out what
works in the offline mode all of these
brands are available online so why would
someone come in here there's something
very special still about seeing it in
person
founder Matt Alexander has been called
the rebel of retail our focus in this
room is creating a sense of magnetism to
the space that has very little to do
with the transaction and much more to do
with that experience sellers sign a
short-term lease sometimes only a month
or two a guarantee there's always
something new for shoppers is a chance
to touch and feel a product they may
have only pointed and clicked on for the
brand's it's a much bigger opportunity
there are hidden cameras all over this
space giving sellers a chance to see
who's buying and how they're interacting
with the product some of the cameras
count heads this little white box here
is a Bluetooth beacon the place with our
others tele information like gender and
what a customer looks at picks up
valuable intelligence brands right now
get an email from us every week that
shows you know sales and feedback from
our stuff but it also has you know how
many people went into your space what is
the general age range you know how
frequently were they transacting hooking
Albert is an online seller of luxury
leather goods hooks and now all of a
sudden you've got that much space the
company is testing out new products here
getting a treasure trove of feedback and
about 20% of its total sales in the
future when we eventually hope to expand
on our physical retail presence and have
stores of our own
data like that is invaluable for us a
little Big Brother all those cameras
shoppers seemed to think it was no big
deal
when you go and shop in stores mostly
everything's on camera
you know you get a ticket it's on camera
so I think that's just a new technology
I feel like every store you know there's
somebody watching security purses so
yeah it's a good store for sure for all
the gains in online selling experts say
this experience can't be replicated a
well produced physical space appealing
to all a customer senses neighborhood
goods next move is into New York City as
the products test out new ways to get
shoppers attention and here's an example
you may have heard of the Dollar Shave
Club it sells men's grooming products
online well they're testing out the idea
of a vending machine for their products
they've got one here in the neighborhood
goods store and you can also find them
places like Mall of America and
LaGuardia Airport just in case you've
forgotten a necessary item your way
somewhere else
thank you very much Janet listen Big
Brother really is watching that's for
sure we are taking receipts and taking
numbers and getting all sorts of data
coming to New York I like it I like it
very much